happening now flight delays and
cancellations at mccarran specifically
for those flying southwest
madison kimbrough is live with more
details madison why is this occurring
from air traffic control issues to
weather those are two of the main
reasons for the delays and the
cancellations
southwest is set to have canceled more
than a thousand flights and the
cancellations mark the highest rate by
far of the major u.s airlines that's
according to a travel analyst and the
southwest airlines pilot association
here's what people on twitter are saying
referencing the long lines and wait
times people laying on benches as they
wait for updates to their flights we
spoke to some travelers extremely
frustrated by the matter we're trying to
find a hotel room because they said we
couldn't get a flight out until tuesday
all of the airlines and everybody's book
the ones that aren't booked
they've raised the cost so high while
it's a beautiful day in las vegas we are
expected to get some windy weather
tomorrow so the chance of increased
delays throughout tomorrow may be
possible
[Music]
the faa tweeted that no air traffic
control shortages were reported since
friday the administration added that
some airlines continue to experience
scheduled challenges due to aircraft and
crews out of place we will keep you
updated all through the newscast coming
up at 6 and 6 30. reporting live madison
kimbrough live local now